Turkish president erdogan supporters
have come out in large numbers to
welcome him
many of the people here in adiaman have
been displaced by February's powerful
earthquakes
one of the worst affected cities in
Turkey to host his first rally after
this month's first round of presidential
election
despite the city's extensive destruction
erdon received more than 66 percent of
the world here he now hopes to maintain
his momentum and get a higher percentage
in the runoff on May 28th he promises
what survivors need
had a famous
we will make this earthquake area a
better and safer place by constructing
000 buildings this year and 650 000 in
total without stopping we will deliver
on our promises
more than a thousand buildings have
collapsed here and around 10 000 people
have died as a result of the earthquakes
while the city is gradually recovering
from the disasters the survivors are
trying to cope many people here
the makeshift tents or containers will
be short and they will be able to move
into houses quickly but nearly four
months after the earthquakes they are
still waiting
this container city is now home to more
than 2 000 people there are several of
them spread across the city hosting
around 40 000 people
femi corkut and his family moved here a
month ago his daughter Layla is
epileptic and suffers recurring seizures
they should build the house and then we
can move there this is our biggest
problem now when it gets hotter we can't
stay in these containers this child
cannot bear this heat neither the cold
the scars of the earthquakes here are
still Vivid Mamu KOJA and his son sir
Khan were trapped under the rubble for
more than 20 hours they survived but he
lost a leg and his son an arm
I need a prosthetic leg and my son needs
an arm we can't live normally like this
we can't do the simplest things I can't
even play properly like this
to meet the needs of so many nearly half
a million new buildings must now be
built in disaster areas
experts say it will take years to
rebuild the devastated cities but the
government promises to finish it in a
year
and president erdogan supporters here
say they want to put their trust in his
promises
Southeastern turkey